la secrétaire d'état auprès de la
ministre des armées geneviève
darrieussecq est arrivé ici au lycée
militaire de saint cyr l'école aux
alentours de 15 heures
elle a rencontré des élèves et des
enseignants du bts cyberdéfense une
formation à la sécurité des réseaux
informatiques et aux systèmes embarqués
un cursus créé en 2010 cette norme est
investi dans ce bts pour pouvoir remplir
les rangs de techniciens spécialisés
dans le cyber dans leur armée donc on
est formés dans le domaine de la cyber
défense on va acquérir
comment bien sécurisé des réseaux
informatiques par exemple le site ont
bien protégé notre ordinateur
donc voilà des programmations ensuite on
a du réseau si il ya aussi du système
donc on va vraiment où on a des
compétences globales dans tous les
domaines
la secrétaire d'état a aussi évoqué le
plan d'investissement de 100 millions
d'euros destinée à la rénovation des
lycées militaires
elle a aussi évoqué les questions de
discriminations et de harcèlement
sexiste dans ces établissements
il faut écouter il faut regarder il faut
dépister faut voir les signaux faibles
bien sûr les signaux forts et faire en
sorte de pouvoir prévenir et faire en
sorte surtout s'il y avait le moindre
problème de pouvoir sanctionner
rapidement et bien nous arriverons à
faire en sorte que ces comportement
d'une minorité qui sont inacceptables ne
se reproduise pas près de 800 élèves ont
fait leur rentrée 2019 2020
au lycée militaire de saint cyr l'école
des étudiants répartis entre le lycée le
bts et les classes préparatoires aux
grandes écoles de l'armée